my name is mano I spent over 20 years in
Romania so it will always be a part of
me it's in my system but now I live in
Paderborn and feel at home here
my mother is France Canada home is
wherever I am right now but home is also
what you make of into quite moist humid
as I observe on the cloud a water Nikita
comes to this Sports Hall in Paderborn
to home nerves together with her husband
average clanton like her a professional
dancer the 27 year old Romanian is
represented her country at three World
Championships and one at countless
tournaments the couple came to
nationwide fame in Germany after
appearing on TV talent show
let's dance
foolish its let's dance let's dance is
the absolute highlight of my career and
the story of my integration integrations
vague vile I met a lot of lovely people
and found a great deal of welcome and
acceptance quantity' each sign so like
to be myself and express my entire
personality
a water Nikita and her husband make
their living primarily as dance
instructors she first donned her dancing
shoes as a young girl she met her
husband at a tournament in Romania and
joined him in Germany four years ago it
was a bit of a culture shock because
everything was so different the
mentality and the punctuality took some
time getting used to there were a lot of
things I had to learn gradually over
time I'm Anne Frank Wickliffe resumed
asthma when I arrived I made an effort
to get another country and its people
and to adapt to the German system I have
to know the rules to be able to play
fair come on a fair spilling over in
Romania for four years now actor daniel
booko has been working at the National
Theatre in Sibiu the Theater stages
productions in both German and Romanian
that one treats a touched on this using
dimensional that people are warmer and
more open than in Germany of months and
Miss Elizabeth Sherman's tend to be a
bit more reserved especially in Bavaria
or the north of the country and this is
my snow it's that curiosity and
eagerness to learn new things that I
noticed the most here and you can see
that in my fellow actors shamiqua d-man
mekdeci de caza de winter sheets the
difference between German and Romanian
drama students is that the Romanians
have a greater presence had a greater
energy giggle on Wednesdays Putin
tonight's play is in German it's a
grotesque comedy by Hungarian dramatist
Jorge Tiwari
for anyone who does not speak German a
simultaneous translation is provided
daniel booko says that Romanians like to
escape to the theatre for comic relief
the cliche about Romanians that annoys
him the most is that they're supposed to
be less aren't working than the Germans
but he doesn't know I know a lot of
people and the idea that they're lazy is
nonsense the pace here is a little
slower like in the Balkans generally
people are easygoing not lazy well
Romania we always heard how the Germans
are perhaps not stiff but not quite as
warm as other people that's how I was
wary of that when I moved here at the
age of 20 because I didn't know how I'd
be accepted but the Germans I met
weren't really like that they gave me a
very warm welcome Afghan on today she
and her husband are having some friends
over for homemade cake the walls are
adorned with pictures of their young son
and highlights from their career their
first meeting in Romania is still a very
fond memory we happen to bump into each
other again at the national
championships which I won you're so mean
that wasn't nice really did become
Romanian champion which I never did it
was so annoying and something he's
always teasing me about
in dunya Bullers case it was romance
that brought him to Romania he arrived
with no work permit and no job prospects
he might have ended up working as a
security guard if he hadn't been
accepted at the theater depends of
freedom if they must get job I'm happy
enough with my life here this is my
girlfriend she's an actor too
unfortunately 180 kilometers away so I
commute back and forth you know me
though when defend a marina near a water
Nikita is taking a stroll through
downtown
paderborn she likes that it's a city but
not too big one of her friends runs a
boutique that specializes in dance wear
and accessories I have to admit it but I
actually started dancing because of the
clothes getting the opportunity to wear
such beautiful dresses and at some point
I succeeded I were this to do the
cleaning today for Awana
national allegiances are no longer that
important she still stays close in touch
with her family in Romania though and
she goes to visit them three times a
year
I'm happy and that's what matters most
this is the Salah v600e feeling me go
inside I still feel germinal not
Romanian in it I was born in Germany and
it's my homeland is in Medina boys don't
give why would I want to deny my roots
that's Ghani Hanif alone and amo
daniel booko certainly feels at home in
Romania and he's in big demand as an
actor
well Oh honor nikichi has found a new
home and more in Germany two Europeans
who are immigrants and very much
established in their new home countries
yeah